[Musique]
oh la vache bien de cet art qu'est -ce
qui cette dame si sa victime
nicki minaj flop flop total c'est la
panthère rose qui a qu'a pris un cours
trop de latex tout le latex scient nicki
minaj de samian
ayem château rails et magnifie c'est
pareil m elle a su valade et elle a des
rondeurs et tout lé montrent un mel b
est mais bien sûr mais j'adore aussi
c'est comme ayem magnifient une femme
avec des formes
déjà moi j'aime top extrêmement
sensuelle extrêmement séduisante
[Musique]
justin assez compliqué de juger une
icône de mode
mon avis est l'emblème patagonie
cristina cordula et très belle femme
allongée même papy les franges en bas
j'en ai sur mon tapis ça fait pas et
christina passants mais c'est pas un top
non plus ma chérie
justin bieber sait justin bieber
d'accord moi je tenais pas les appliquer
ça va pas du tout au talent son caleçon
et ses capotes doivent être avec ses
initiales wilquin falls
shy'm et alors ça c'est donc le talent
me affriolantes me sexy une sorte de
sirène 2.0 c'est évidemment pour un
tapis rouge pas faire de courses à
carrefour avec ça ne va pas fort
ces deux langues oui alors là c'est
conceptuel cette personne me fait peur
je trouve que c'est absolument immonde
plat
[Musique]
bizarre isabelle morini bosc mais c'est
rapide à notre âge parce que j'adore
c'est qu'elle a son style à elle
or les colifichets on dirait un vieux
truc de marché aux puces de la mode
c'est toi qui l'a fait c'est ahmad rayon
enlevé lingling à soual mais revendique
eti cotées cruella dans la maison
dalmatiens j'adore ton style
isa je laime comme ça vous voulez
retrouver des conseils des vrais
conseils
non mais je plaisante pas parce que je
suis vraiment fan de mode et bien voulu
retrouver sur les instantanés de valérie
bénaïm point com